hello everyone it's nice beer Thank You
Tyler folks for calling me just a small
note
this actually I need to kind of know
what everyone wants to do do you folks
want to do the set up as well I mean do
you want to set up your environments and
actually do it yourself or so the reason
I'm asking this is because I'll have to
pace the rest users you have to pace the
rest of my tutorial accordingly so what
I'm going to do is first tell you to
look for me on github
I am Hardwell waiter with two E's like
Darth Vader I made that a long time ago
don't judge so please try and find me
and once you finally go to my personal
Jupiter notebooks which is called
personal and you should come down to
here which is personal slash notebooks
slash text analysis tutorial so I'm
going to give you just a minute to find
this URL take your time
once you get here which is I suppose a
minute I'm gonna ask you some questions
again okay so this makes things easier
since the network is congested it means
that it's highly unlikely you folks are
all going to find the page do the
downloads and do everything so what I'm
going to do and this is extremely
extremely important please note down
this URL because it would be really cool
if once this is all over you could go
back and actually to set up your
environments on your own on your
personal machines later but a huge part
of this tutorial is you folks all going
back and doing text analysis later so
please take your time down to get this
repository and this particular URL there
are multiple dupa dupa notebooks
multiple tutorials resources links and a
bunch of things which will help you in
life and text analysis so take your
maybe a minute to just make sure you
find it yeah yeah of course
hold on so are you having trouble
looking at this
I'm afraid I don't know how to zoom in
on the URL is it still a problem or can
you have a look just to help you find it
github comm / Bhargav vader so like once
you find this over here this is my
github username if you go to github
slash this it should be fairly easy to
find personal so again I'm just going to
give like two to five minutes for you to
find this repository and for you to find
this link before I continues that's like
two to five minutes I'm sorry
is it like there's no one have internet
then okay that's okay so um what I'm
going to do is okay so can everyone see
this URL over here not just at least
note this URL down on your take a
picture of it or load this URL down even
if you don't have internet just take
this down github.com slash I mean that
that particular one so even if the
network is down even if you cannot log
on to the Internet you should have this
it's nine three of which like nine five
and then
okay it's 95 so hoping everyone has
settled down more or less I will of
course at the end of the tutorial talk
about the link and all of these things
just to make it very clear why I'm so
particular about this is because
normally a huge part of the tutorial is
walking everyone through setting up a
virtual environment and setting up the
packages required to do text analysis of
course having anaconda or having your
virtual environment already set up would
mean this would be normally very
straightforward but this is a very
important part of the tutorial because I
would like like I said before I would
really like everyone to go home and
continue doing their text analysis so
just a point before I actually start
talking about what we're going to be
doing this link has like I said all the
material both reading material and code
which you would need to get started on
your own later and it would be really
cool if everyone could check it out
later and you know it's a github
repositories of course issues pull
requests if you have any problem
suggestions anything then it would be
incredibly useful ok so we're going to
start now
and in this tutorial I mean like the
name of the tutorial it's a text
analysis tutorial I call it topic strips
tricks and tips and text analysis so one
thing to make clear I will not be going
so much into depth I would rather be
going into breadth I'm going to be
talking about why you should do text
analysis why you should do it in Python
and what are the different kind of
things which you can actually do I just
want to give you a taste of all the cool
things you can do and once you have a
taste you can actually go and cook your
own stuff up you can figure out which
part of text analysis appeals to you
which part of it could be useful for
your personal work your research or
business and you can actually get
started but overall I'm just going to
try and give you a motivation of why
is--why technologies is really cool and
also really important so one thing I
would also like to specifically talk
about is the libraries and packages
which we will be using why this is
important is because I want to focus on
industry standard or industry strength
code we are not going to be writing
sloppy academic code which no one is
going to look at later
I mean you can still write your sloppy
academic code it's just that if you'd
want to get anything into production and
if it also if you want to move out of
sandbox and then these are your going to
be needing the tools I'm going to talk
about for example one of my pet peeves
is n ltk most people when they think of
oh we're gonna do some natural language
processing like let's do a little TK
let's bring our eyes the firm and I
react to that horribly I say no
absolutely not you should really stop
using n l TK n l TK is academic code
it's bloated it has a lot of things that
you are not going to be using and
honestly it's really not as well
maintained as as other packages out
there are so that would be one of the
first example to the kind of methodology
you'd want to you know follow so stop
using packages which are academic and
bloated and use more efficient packages
so our huge part of fact I mean huge
part of what I'll be talking about is a
package called Spacey Spacey is I
believe written by folks from Berlin
actually and by Matt Hana ball and Innes
who've done a great job with the library
it's really fast it has a lot of nice
features which I think it eclipses n LT
K in terms of just you know the best
possible way to do a certain task and I
cannot recommend it enough so that's
another part of it we'll be importing
Spacey as well so Spacey is used for the
computational linguistics and the
pre-processing part of our code then
we're going to be using Jensen which
stands for generate similarity which is
a really popular text processing library
as well we're going to be using it for
topic modeling I'll be getting into a
topic modeling is in a bit then we're
gonna be using pardon me we're gonna be
using Kira switch some of you might have
used before or heard of Kira's is a deep
learning or a neural network based
library so we'll be using Kira's as well
and we'll be using scikit-learn which
also most people who work with data at
some point would have heard about before
so this is just to introduce you to the
kind of tools we'll be using throughout
the tutorial we'll be running it on a
Jupiter notebook you'll be using Python
and that's pretty much it so I mean
that's pretty much it regarding our the
technical infrastructure of what we'll
be doing now about text analysis
now one of the particular reasons why I
really enjoy working on hex analysis is
you know the personal nature of the data
it so happens so you know for example
sometimes when you're working with I
don't know like normal first thing which
people work on and machine learning
might be the iris dataset where you have
to classify the iris dataset into the
four different kinds of flowers based on
you know the petal width and all this
stuff it just it's cool I mean you're
you know using the width of your petals
of her flowers to decide what kind of
flower it is but honestly I could not
care less about these flowers and the
reason why I started doing text analysis
is because I wanted to be personally
involved with the data I was working
with and what's really cool about text
analysis is you can actually use your
own data you can use your own Facebook
messages and whatsapp messages you can
use your own emails you can use if you
like a particular book and you happen to
have illegally download off them trying
to not do that but if you did you can
analyze that as well it's really cool
the kinds of things that you can do with
text data and personal text data which
is why I which is my usual motivation
behind telling people why you should do
text analysis you can do really cool
things on your own but of course why to
do text analysis is a talk of its own I
mean what I want to of course get into
now is what we're actually going to do
so we're going to start right now please
feel free to stop me uh if you have any
questions or what I'm going to be doing
is just running the Jupiter notebook and
talking about the code so honestly even
if we did have internet what you would
be doing is pressing enter with me so
you're not really missing out on too
much by not having the Jupiter notebook
I just like everyone to have it because
it gives you a sense of accomplishment
and it's nice to see the results but
it's still okay we're still going to
learn a lot and have a good time but
again like I've mentioned before follow
my link and please download this for
yourself later when you have go
somewhere where you have internet or
back in your homes or whatever so okay
let's let's get started so like I
mentioned a huge what what exactly we'll
be focusing on is the entire pipeline of
text analysis I want to walk you through
you know actually getting your data to
the kind of things you can do note about
getting your data
okay I actually have a actual note on it
okay so let me just start my imports so
I mentioned I talked about some of the
packages before and these are the
packages we'll be using so we're using
piano to power our keys this notice for
Kearse I don't want to listen to
warnings at the moment because it makes
the note book not look as pretty but and
also want my plots to be in line so I'm
doing matplotlib in line gathering data
so why now a huge huge part of our text
analysis in general like I mentioned
before is the personal nature of data
now it's kind of mean of me to talk
about how fun personal data is and then
after that using newspaper corpus
because that's what we're doing but the
main one of the main reasons is because
when I actually started doing the
tutorial along with the data gathering
part it ended up becoming a really
really long tutorial I honestly think
you can spend an hour and a half on just
gathering your data some of they're like
one of my favorite places to gather data
is Twitter mainly because it's a lot of
rich textual data you have a lot of day
I really like using reddit as well for
gathering data
reddit's api is also pretty neat and the
thing about reddit is because it's JSON
text which is structured read it is a
noose aggregation website where you can
find a noose links and not just noose
all kinds of entertainment and links but
you can find in the comments section
it's quite an active comment section you
can find lots of structured questions
and answers and replies allowing you to
really get this get rich internet data
really really fast so these are some of
the places you can actually gather your
data from I also talked about using your
own personal data before for example in
whatsup if you hold down your
conversation you have an option to email
the entire chat to yourself so you can
email or chat yourself and start
analyzing your whatsapp conversations so
these are some of the places where you
can collect it or you can use
beautifulsoup to actually you know like
mine websites and get data off you know
like actually using website data so
there's many ways you can gather data
and a huge part of text analysis after
gathering your data is pre-processing
now pre-processing is super important
and of course any kind of machine
learning or data analysis
data science kind of job but in text
analysis it becomes extremely extremely
important you're all going to see why it
becomes so important in just a small bit
but as for now a little bit about the
corpus one of the core purposes we're
going to be using immediately it's the
lead background corpus
it's newspaper articles 300 of them from
2000 and 2001 it's an Australian
newspaper agency so the news is going to
be focused more on Australian news but a
little bit of international news as well
the reason why we're using this data set
is because it's easy to use it's on
Jenson so all I have to do is as long as
you have Jenson installed you can easily
load the data it's easier for me to show
you examples of the things we can do if
I use this data set personally I don't
like this data set it because it's kind
of depressing news in 2000 2001 was kind
of depressing so but this is what we're
going to be using for this data set you
can always use your own data when you
actually try this out later
so that just loads up your data set it's
basically I'm using the Jenson pad to
find the test the test data and then
after that I'm downloading it again if
you have any doubts whoops if you have
any doubts regarding any lines of the
code please do stop me or if something
is not clear
I talked earlier about why you should
use Spacey and not ltk so one of the
main so I know what are the first things
that you do in text analysis is like I
mentioned before pre-processing and one
of the first things which we do in
pre-processing is getting rid of
something called stop words stop words
are basically words which we think don't
add any information to our our final
results so one of one of the things that
we do is before
for example words like articles like a
in this is of course in the context of
English but I would like to note that
most or if not all most of the things
I'll be talking about is of course
extended to German to French to most
modern languages so stop words are words
which are not going to add any useful
information to our results so we'd want
to get rid of stop words in different
ways now to give you an example of how
an old ticker would have done this n ltk
allows you analytic allows you to import
an entire list of stop words so you have
a massive list of stop word so you add
you know you just import this list and
then you can actually add words to this
list by you know however we add like
just append appending words and what you
would do is you would go through your
entire your entire data set and you
would say if the word is not in stop
lists stop words add this word you know
so you would actually go down this is
how you would do it with NLT kay now the
cool thing about Spacey is Spacey and
this is actually the main selling point
and I would argue this is one of the
most important parts of this tutorial is
a Spacey uses something called language
models so what a language model does is
it basically processes your text now
when it processes your text it does many
many things to it one of the things it
does is identifies what stop words are
in your text identify is which one of
your letters or numbers it identifies
which which part of your text R is
punctuation it identifies in your Center
it identifies each of your sentences
separately it identifies your documents
it tells you for example if you want to
find out which words in your sentence
are words it has that information as
well now the best part about this is for
example if you are doing the same exact
thing when n ltk you would
need a part of speech tagger for example
and you'd run this part of part of
speech tagger on your sentence and then
it would tag it and you would print it
so you would have four different
processes of your text analysis pipeline
you would have different tools which you
would pick from NLT Kay by the way when
I'm talking about ltk I mean any other
tool which you can use so you'd rather
you pick out different kind of tools for
different kinds of tasks and they'd use
all of them and this is not always the
best thing to do it's nice to have one
pipeline which does everything and this
is why spacey is super super cool with
just this bit of code NLP is equal to
space seed outload en you are doing a
lot of things what exactly is going on
when I do space seed upload en I am
loading Spacey's English model for
example if I was going to use if I was
working on German language text I would
use space seed upload de encodes there's
different ways to load language models
and you can actually just search space
see language models download for
different ways I have links on the
repository as well but you would first
need to download a language model based
on how complicated or intense you want a
language model to be it can be 45 MB to
even a GB so depending on what exactly
you want to use your language model for
so you'd start out with downloading your
language model which would be pip
install whatever or you can actually do
space C download the name of the
language model so based on how you want
to download it you would download your
language model once you download your
language model and it's in the same
it'll be in the same directory as your
space C it mean if you want it to be the
same directory space installation and
you would do this NLP is space it out
load en and there we go we have now LP
is our was what we would call our
pipeline so I would call NLP my pipeline
which I've loaded from space II because
I did en it's my English language
pipeline so I talked about stop words
earlier so the way space C deals with
stop words is when it analyzes your text
through its pipeline it annotates or it
tags different words as stop words now
I've done this experiment on this
particular corpus before so I know for a
fact
that the words which I've mentioned over
there are stop words or words I think do
not add useful information for example
it's a newspaper corpus right which
means that you're gonna have a lot of
people saying mister some so-and-so said
something about something now words like
mister and said are not useful
information to me if I want to find out
unique words or special words in my
corpus so you notice how I add says
saying I mean different variations of
the word said and today and mister so
that I want to ignore these words as
part of my final analysis I'm going to
you're gonna probably understand a bit
later about why exactly I'm doing this
for now you're gonna have to take my
word for it that these words do not add
any useful information to my results but
I'm going to come back and show you
exactly why the reason I put this code
over here is for you to have a look at
how you in space see how you add an
extra word tutor a stop word list so
what we do over here is for the stop
word in my list of stop words lexeme is
the linguistic unit which Spacey
converts each word to and I basically
say lexeme is stop which is is it a
stopper it's true so I'm basically
forcing Spacey to consider all of these
words as stop words yes okay so that's a
very good question the question is it
doesn't Spacey know that all of these
words like say said it says and saying
especially these four words because at
the same root yeah so it doesn't Spacey
know that they're all the same word yes
it does and I'm going to explain why I
would still need to do this in a small
bit we're definitely going to talk about
it yeah so right now you're going to
mean I'm just going to add these words
and now what I'm going to do and this is
the really important part is I'm going
to actually process my entire text using
my pipeline so just a small reminder
text is what I downloaded off the
Jennsen which is my corpus so here text
should be whatever personal data you
want to use if you don't want to use the
newspaper data set and what I'm doing is
that my document which I'm going to
contain my space often is equal to NLP
of text up lower now texts are lower or
here is a personal choice because I
don't care for
punctuation in topic modeling which is
what I'm going to show a bit later so I
did text out lower if for you you know
for example if you need punctuation or
if you need capitalization then you do
not do text out lower for me I needed to
do it so I do text out lower this is a
computationally intensive part of the
code because you're actually so when I
when I'm like running this so this is
like this is magic this is super cool
this is very fun so what's going on is
I'm actually passing my entire text
through my space pipeline NOP
it just reminder and appease my Spacey
pipeline text is my text and there we go
so this takes some time but yeah so
what's going on over here is like image
yeah blue doesn't work so the
instructions to download the file are
actually on the you know the page which
I talked about earlier this page like my
github this yeah and the other thing is
it's the pretty much one of the first
things you do when you download space is
you download space see and then you
download the language model which you
want to use so for example if you're
working with English or German data you
the first thing you do is pip install
Spacey and once you put install Spacey
you would do Spacey download en and
these instructions I've if you yeah ok
so I've actually mentioned downloading
spacey language model over here so you
okay so awesome so you can see the six
Jupiter uh doc is done which means now
technically this these first six lines
of code are one of the biggest takeaways
from this tutorial it's not it doesn't
seem that impressive but honestly it
really really is learning I mean just
how to set up Spacey for your personal
text analysis projects is really really
useful so what exactly happened let's
look at doc
so you can see for example in the first
document hundreds of people have been
forced okay their homes everything is of
course in lowercase there's year these
are newspaper articles and each you can
see that each over here there's a new
line each new line is your new article
there are 300 articles over here it
doesn't look like anything has actually
happened right I mean when I look at Doc
it's just the entire text what's
happening is every single word over here
has been annotated now for example
hundreds of people so on and so forth
each word each token inside Doc now has
a lot of rich information let me show
you so we are now going to be a that
what happened just before was - we'll be
using this later like Doc will be using
the doc variable the dark object later
what I what I want to show you I mean
what the last seven lines of code was
was how exactly you set up the dark
object after you load up a pipeline and
you run the code in now I'm actually
going to show you the what the kind of
things you can do using these Doc's so
I'm now going to run a bunch of
experiments on smaller sentences the
reason is because it's easy for me to
show you the results of these operations
on smaller sentences once I show you the
results of these operations we're going
to go back to using dot but this is just
illustrative so last time what happened
was we used an entire doc was the entire
newspaper corpus now we're gonna go
sentence by sentence sentence I'm sorry
so sentence is equal to NLP again is my
English pipeline of this is my sentence
and this is of course a lot faster so
the first thing we're gonna see which
Spacey does I told you a lot of things
happen under the hood right a lot of
annotations happen a lot of information
what exactly so one of the first things
I'm gonna show you is called pasta and
pasta tagging stands for part of speech
tagging so in English at least for
example in a sentence we have parts of
speech like word noun articles and so on
and so forth now we can find what kind
of parts of speech
their inner sentences once we finish
passing anything to a Spacey's pipeline
so here for token incent which is for
token in sentence I'm going to print the
text the part of speech and the tag so
you can see over here Tom went to Ikea
to get some of those delicious Swedish
meatballs Swedish is an adjective
okay so but you can see we're here that
Tom for example is a proper noun
so it's marked as a proper noun over
there went is a word so you can see it's
marked as a worm so you can see how just
when we passed our text through spaces
pipeline we didn't tell Spacey to do
this in particular but Spacey has
already annotated every single word
which means over here every single word
and all 300 of these documents in the
example before has all been annotated of
this kind of information the part of
speech the original text
what kind of tag it is as for if you
want more information about exactly what
these tags stand for I'm not going to
get into details of that I'd recommend
you to go into space seize part of
speech tagging documentation which tells
you what every single tag stands for and
then you can decide if you want to use
it in your own work or not but this is
something very cool Spacey does along
with all the other annotation it has
marked parts of speech as well I just
want to stop and ask if there's any
questions or if everything is clear so
far yeah
yep
I'm just gonna try and break that mean
so your question is yeah yeah so the
reason I did it to lower a normally
Spacey does not do it to lower
I mean Spacey can tell you if it's
capitalized or not but Spacey doesn't
the reason I did to lower before and
this you'll understand later is that
there's a bug right now in Spacey's
current version which means that if a
stop word starts with a capital letter
it is not caught as a stop word for
example a word but if it's a capital B
then and which is normally a stopper it
would not be caught as a stop word so
the reason I do lower is to make sure
that everything is caught a stop words
but also because in that example for Doc
I would later be showing you results of
topic modeling where it doesn't matter
if it's capitalized or not so in this
particular case because I'm just
illustrating illustrator II sentences
I'm not making it all into lowercase but
normally depending on the kind of text
analysis you want to do if you want to
do an exploratory text analysis where
you just want to learn about the nature
of your text it doesn't really matter if
your word is a capital letter or not
unless you're looking for the number of
capital letters in your text in which
case different ballgame but normally it
really depends on what your end game is
in the previous example my end game was
topic modeling which I'll talk about
later and in topic modeling punctuation
and spelling does not matter so I made
it lower but normally a Spacey does not
make into lower because Spacey annotates
the words as they are okay so that was
passed agging what we're going to be
doing now is something called any are
tagging any R stands for named entity
recognition so in this particular case
named entities are for example if you
would say that
well Emmanuel macron is the president of
France Emmanuel Macau is an end as a
named entity because he is
there's only one Emmanuel macron who is
the president of France so it's
considered a named entity and president
is an entity where there's many possible
precedents you can have President of the
golfing club or whatever you can have
many kinds of presidents so this is not
caught as unnamed entity named entities
can be geopolitical
geopolitical objects it can be places it
can be company's time if it's a
particular time like 4:00 p.m. on
Thursday and that's a particular named
entity so named entities are all as the
name suggests they're named entities but
you can you can again I would recommend
going to Spacey's page and searching up
what exactly named entities are and how
it might be useful to you this is
actually a huge part of natural language
processing research a lot of people use
named entities you can example you can
imagine for example if you're building a
chatbot and you'd want if someone says I
need to book something for something
it'll be important to find named
entities in your text so this is just a
possible way where it could be useful
again Spacey does all of this the one
time I ran this space he already has
information about your past and your
ners and everything I'm gonna give you
an example so you can see four three of
them you have Tom which is a person
because that's a particular person I key
as an organization and Swedish is and n
are but not sure exactly what but I
believe here it's named
okay so it says nationalities or
religious or political groups so Spacey
has correctly identified Swedish as an
norp which is named on dirty or
religious groups so this is what I mean
you can go to the Spacey linguistic
features page which is again not loading
because Internet's not so nice but but
yeah you get the idea I mean you do get
the idea right that's clear okay okay
this question
the tax which are not packed like this
delicious meatballs are they stop words
no they're just not named entities okay
I'll give you an example just your so
you can notice that over here I did for
token incent so I actually went through
every single token in my sentence and
then if this token had a named entity
tag I asked that to be printed but over
here I'm doing four end in sentence so
it's four entity in sentences entities
and the only three entities in this
sentence are Tom and IKEA and Swedish
another really really cool thing about
aspasie is it has very nice JavaScript
based visualizations called display C
and you can import display C as part of
your it's a module in Spacey and you can
act you can do cool visualizations it's
not as cool with named entities because
I mean this is what it does which is so
friendly cool I suppose but you can do
even cooler visualizations using Spacey
so I would recommend checking out this
place you later we're gonna be I'm gonna
show you a small while later right now
but so when you look at computational
linguistics as a field in general there
are certain things which which are
considered part for example part of
speech tagging any are tagging and
dependency parsing I would say these
three are the pillars of computational
linguistics and largely in text analysis
I would like to break up text analysis
maybe roughly into a more statistical
learning part of text analysis or
natural language processing part of text
analysis and computational linguistics
part of text analysis so so far what
we've seen with part of speech tagging
and any art tagging this is the
computational linguistics part of text
analysis just to note before we go ahead
so dependency parsing depending
dependency parsing is really cool I mean
as the name suggests we're going to
parse our sentences and identify the
dependencies or the relationships
between words in
sentence so between the words in a
sentence how are they related to each
other subjects and objects and so on and
so forth now dependency parsing in
itself is a huge linguistic you know you
there's a lot to study in it so I'm not
going to get into details of what
exactly it is if you think it could be
useful for yourself please get into the
research behind it is actually very very
neat but just to give you an idea of
what it looks like um so here what we
did was it's Tom went IKEA to those two
meatballs you have n sub P herbs and P
up here it's the subject and the object
of the sentences so here tom is the
subject and the object are his delicious
Swedish meatballs so that's how the
sentence is broken up now for me when I
normally work with dependency parsing
this kind of information is not only not
very pretty but it's not very useful
it's kind of tough to wrap your head
around it unless you already know what
dependency parsing is and people do like
you know people get degrees in
linguistics and study dependency parsing
so it's sometimes difficult to
understand this but spacey renders this
pretty well so over here you can see so
just some information Spacey makes this
this particular image using the
information from here so we use this
information you can learn to interpret
this information better later but so
what happens over here is in dependency
parsing verbs the verb or the action is
the the root and everything else is
linked because you would say tom is a
subject which is doing the action on the
object and so on so over here there are
two herbs get and went so these are the
you know the two cores of the sentences
so again this is just to give you an
idea of the things you can do with
Spacey I'm not going to explain what
dependency parsing is because that's
really another tutorial but this is just
to give you an you know an idea of the
kind of things you can do if this is if
this and you can also create your own
dependencies and your own meanings for
example if you you could also create
dependencies for adjectives if you'd
want a graph like this which says
delicious Swedish meatballs if you want
delicious to be linked to Swedish
meatballs as you know
it's providing information to it you can
train your Spacey model to perform this
custom annotation so it's a lot you can
do regarding dependencies and
relationships between sentences this
dependency parsing there's two kinds one
is dependency parsing one is
constituency parsing constituency
parsing breaks our sentence up into word
phrases noun phrases so basically this
is linguistics this is the linguistics
part you know off text analysis and I
want to expose you to this so that in
case even if one of you finds this
useful later you can go back and do it I
would also recommend checking out
exactly what Spacey's guidelines and
annotations are for these particular
linguistic operations so yeah so this is
there's a lot of informations we have
information about parts of speech named
entities dependency I mean all of these
dependencies in that one line of code
when we ran it through the pipeline so
you can see why I kept going on and on
about why I think this is the coolest
thing in the fact that the vi Jupiter
sort of thing was vi vi Jupiter cell
which actually ran my text to the
pipeline when we did that we have all
this information so is that clear does
everyone on board is there any questions
anyone wondering why I'm doing this
anything yeah cool
awesome um just to note you wouldn't
notice that over here I in the examples
a part of speech tagging and NER tagging
and dependency parsing I want my whole
sentence I want my whole sentence
because I want relationships between my
sentence and I don't want a really pre
process you know I want to understand my
entire sentence but many times when we
were doing text analysis we want to run
machine learning or statistical
algorithms on our text when we're
running statistical algorithms on our
text I talked about stop words earlier
and we had a question about say and said
and saying and so on as well and there's
basically cleaning cleaning is involved
when we're running machine learning
algorithms the reason for example I'm
going to very brief very soon talk about
topic models so I'm going to use this
time to briefly introduce topic models
topic models are a class of machine
learning algorithms such
allow you to identify topics in text for
example imagine you are all running not
all but all why not you're all running
the newspaper agencies and you happen to
have 10 or 12 years of newspaper
articles in online format and you have
the person who was in charge before you
obviously did a horrible job and has an
annotated anything and you have no idea
this is completely unstructured text so
if you want to try and understand
completely unstructured text it means
you cannot run you cannot do your
clustering algorithms as well because
it's just kind of messy and of course
it's not classified so if you want to
try and figure out what underlying
themes are going to be present in your
text topic modeling is a good approach
for example in the context of newspapers
what kind of topics would I expect to
see in a bunch of newspaper articles
maybe politics sports weather and so on
and so I cannot economics maybe so when
I when I'm gonna expect to run a topic
modeling algorithm on a newspaper corpus
I'd want to see these kind of underlying
topics come out now just a little bit
more information about topic modeling we
don't name the topics ourselves and we
don't give any information to the
algorithm apart from the number of
topics what we get is a bunch of words
which have a high probability of
occurring around each other for example
if you are running it on American news
in 2016 which is the elections you might
have maybe Hurricane Katrina notice I
think some time around then so you'd
have news about a hurricane which would
be one topic maybe you'd have news about
elections and Trump and Hillary in one
topic maybe and sports and so on and so
forth so you would have a topic zero
with a bunch of words which are current
high probability all of these words
would have to be to do with one
particular topic so you want to identify
topics in text and so why would you not
want stop words in your topic syntax for
example imagine we had a topic which was
a and the went go and this is not
providing any information to me about my
corpus which is why you'd want to get
rid of stop words in the first place and
as for the question which you asked
about why how the spacy when one thing
about the word say said and saying and
so on
what it could what you considered a stop
word is really up to you there is no
official list of stop words there are
suggested list of stop words and even in
different domains like if you work in
biology or different kinds of domains
you'd have a different list of stop
words now the way Spacey annotates stop
words is not through the root of the
word but through the word itself now
another part of pre-processing which
I'll get to immediately is something
which we call limit ization or so
basically what lemma tight a limitation
is it gives you the root word among the
word which you're using for example in
the example of say said it's saying and
so on I would only want the word to say
because for example again if I have a
topic with say said it's saying it not
really getting much information now if I
can condense all that into one word a
root word say this is useful for me but
the way Spacey marks it stop words or it
doesn't say that I doesn't think that
space say is a root stop word on all the
words which come from Sayre stop words
you'd have to say that say you'd have to
say that all of these words are stop
words and this so happened to have the
same root but you see now why I had to
actually individually catch out every
possible variants of the word say and
mark them as stop words because while
Spacey does know that the root of all of
these words is say it does not take that
into account while deciding stop words
is that clear okay so I talked about
topics and I talked about why we'd not
want stop words in our topics right
let's think of other things which we
might not want in our topics we probably
don't want punctuation like we don't
want full stops and commas and colons I
do not want numbers and in this
particular case I also don't want I
which is I mean explain the fader but in
this case what I'm going to do right now
is I'm going to only use important
information from my text to generate my
corpus it's this again this particular
bit of code is very very important so if
you do not understand why we're doing
something please stop me what I want to
do is I want to create a corpus
which can later be used for machine
learning algorithms right so you can see
over here that what I'm doing is if you
remember the original structure of the
data set every new line was a new
document right so what I want to make
sure it's a movement I hit a new line I
want to store a new document so you can
see the moment the text the moment I see
a new line start I make my I append my
article to my entire text and I clear
our article I see some slightly confused
faces so I'm going to go over this again
a bit slower let's look at what's going
on for W in doc which means that for
every single token in my original
document what is doc just to give you a
quick reminder this is doc so for W in
doc is literally for hundreds of people
so I'm going through every single word
in my document so for every single word
in my document if that word is not a
newline if it's not a stop word if it is
not a punctuation if it's not a number
and if it's not I again which is not
caught as a stop word then I want to add
that particular word to my corpus or to
my data set yeah so lemma what do you
see over here lemma is the lemma ties
diversion of the word yes yeah so again
this is actually a spacey bug which I
just figured out yesterday so what
happens is I its lemma ties form the
word I is considered as pronoun so for
some reason it was messing up the
results so I basically made an again I
know for a fact that I is not an
important information to me so I
particularly catch I over here so this
is more like a bug I mean it's I'm just
trying to make sure that I don't catch I
yeah
BAM so again since you do point it out
normally the reason I had to do that was
I is caught as a pronoun when space he
finds a limited version of the word so I
was trying to avoid that bug in my code
so I but then I forgot I actually made
it lower in the whole place it's not
gonna catch that wonderful thank you
okay so let's get back to what is going
on so if it's not a new line if it's not
a stop where basically if it's not what
I consider useful information to me stop
words are not useful information numbers
are not useful information punctuation
is not useful information then I'm going
to add that word but not just toward the
limit eyes version of the word what does
this mean this means like we talked
about before words I'm just getting the
root for example again I used say so I'm
just going at it saying said say all
have the root word say so I don't want
to add a different version of the word
every time I come across the same
semantic meaning so I add only the root
that this root is called the lemma Thais
version of the word there's another way
to do this it's called stemming standing
basically like just tax off the last
part of the word but it's kind of ugly
and damaging and I don't like it so
again this is a personal preferences I
personal preference I think limit izing
look is prettier I like my text analysis
to be nice and pretty and clean so
that's what I use but you can use
stemming as well to do your word cutting
so what I do over here so and then after
that if I do find a new line it means
I've reached the end of my document so
I'd want to start doing the same process
for my next document which is why I
append my article to my text text is a
list which you can see I've initialized
in the beginning of my Jupiter node in
the cell and I make article again empty
so I can start collecting words in my
article is this very clear and why we're
doing what we're doing and how we're
doing it well to be fair this is
actually I mean you mean for
pre-processing text so the reason why
there's no helper function which does
this exactly is because people
pre-process text very differently based
on what they want to do it is really
impossible to say some people might want
numbers for example so in that case
you'd want you I would just remove that
numbers part some people might be for
example there is actually research on
the way stop words
are important in for example in the
style of an author in which case I would
want stop words some people consider
stop words to be the absolute basic part
of pre-processing in some cases you
might actually want it so what's
happening over here for example like I
mean it looks like a lot but I'd like to
remind you this is like literally five
lines of code or four lines of code and
before this my doc is equal to NLP of
the sentences again one line of code
using if use NLT care for example to
find pause tags verbs stop words numbers
punctuation you would have 30 lines of
Python code 30 lines of Python quotes a
lot of code so here in roughly six or
seven lines of code I'm cleaning my text
completely also I'd like to point out
that in some cases you might want your
topic models to how no words in which
case I would do I would get rid of herbs
using the pass function before so I have
a lot of information with me right now
the way and using this information is
I'm using these parts of it but you can
run once you pass your text through your
pipeline you can do a lot of cool things
with it this is just one of the things
I'm doing yeah
okay so you so it depends on when you
say handle abbreviations you'd want to
get rid of them you'd want to include
them you'd want to yeah sweet molasses
is like a very different ballgame in the
sense that it you'd have to again when
it comes to things like this it'd have
to be very particular for example when
you say abbreviations you mean like any
kind of I don't know like etc I mean ago
yeah any kind of slang so you'd have to
write code for that Spacey so just for
information likes PC has pre-loaded
models for different kinds of things
you'd want to do so if there's something
in particularly you actually want to do
you can there's likely a spacey model
which handles that particular thing or
if you really really want to do it and
it's a business you can actually pay
Spacey to download a model to do it I
mean I'm just like or you can write code
to get around it so you'd have to write
your own hack to get around it because
it's not a super common thing like in
traditional computational mystics wasn't
I supposed built for slang flying in
general it's tough to catch but there's
a lot of Spacey models which catch
particular things so and it's also not
super difficult to write exceptions or
write added functionality to your spacey
pipeline it's easy to add new pipeline
functionalities but for your particular
case I'm not sure I've not worked on
that I mean particular part before so
just to give you an idea what texts
looks like um so you saw before the dark
right which had all the words so now if
you've noticed it says hundred people
forced okay to home Southern Highlands
so you can see all the words which I
believe have had no meaning like I am
the and all stuff like that have all
been removed this only contains useful
information so texts is a list of lists
where the inner lists are each of the
documents with the words non important
and things removed and of course split
up it's not a string it's each
a separate word and all of these lists
are put together a massive list which is
my final data structure is everyone you
have an idea of what this data structure
looks like a list of lists with words
inside it
so I'm gonna talk about now we're going
to be using Jensen for the first time
Jensen is the oh god Hafner so I talked
about using Jensen and what we're going
to do using Jensen we're going to be
doing making by grams by grams are
basically in some cases when we're
dealing with large bodies of text some
words tend to are collocations these are
called collocations of high grams
some groups of words tend to make more
sense together like new and York for
example it just makes more sense in New
York so one possible way we can do this
is using Jensen's phrases module which
creates these diagrams for us I'll give
you more an example which is more
relevant to this particular data set for
example this was 2000 and 2001 okay
which meant that yes yes
so uh so articles are stop words yes so
the thing is articles are stop words
because stop words are any words which
do not add useful information so a and
the do not add any useful information
please go ahead of course there's a lot
of cases in which case it's interesting
in which case for example articles are
also a part of speech so you can just
write one extra line of code which would
be but if it's an article put it in the
code so it this really depends for
example if your particular analysis
articles are useful so do not remove
them in the pre-processing but normally
and traditionally in all cases of text
analysis articles are considered stop
words no problem
so for example you said if the stop word
refers to something else right but I'm
not removing what it refers to I'm just
removing the stop word so okay for
example what do you mean like in New
york-new if news the stop word and then
I get rid of new the New York doesn't
have any information do you mean
something like that for example okay
of course you don't remove the words
from the sentence so if you want a
particular stop word to be removed or
not removed you can like I've done in
the sentence before where I did for say
saying mister and so on you can like
hard court Spacey to consider words to
stop words or not stop words there is no
one Universal list of its top words
works or not for every project you keep
adding or removing stop words based on
the results you want to see so if you
feel that certain words are going to be
useful later like if you see there's a
semantic relationship between a capital
A or a capital B and a particular entity
then you just have to be very careful in
your code to make sure that you don't
get rid of that on accident yeah so I
talked about by grams by grams are
basically words which have more sense
together so in this case this is how I
make my by grams I'm going to do this a
bit faster so text is equal to make by
gram offline for my line in texts to
give you an example of what happened or
earlier on over here New South Wales
right but New South Wales a state in
Australia and it makes more sense if
that was considered together you can see
over here New South is one word so this
changes your dictionary is this clear so
basically words which tend to appear
more often together are caught together
and this is you don't probably using
probability yes
so in that case what you would do is I
would do if I basically run a buy grams
again it becomes trigrams so in this
case I'm only looking for buy grams
because I'm doing four line in text and
it's a one phrase model if I want to be
sure to catch multiple phrases out and
again you can have 4 grams 5 grams and
grams basically in this case just to
give you an example it's 2 so it's new
south so I don't think to remember is
that of course for most machine learning
algorithms I mean in fact all you cannot
feed a raw text as your input to any
algorithm you would need to convert this
raw text into a vectorized form so the
machine learning algorithm can deal on
vectors again when we deal with any kind
of machine learning algorithms we use
vectors or numbers and not words so we
need to convert our basically this list
of Lists which just has words into
something more meaningful which a
computer can understand an easy way to
do this is to just create a dictionary
so to give you an example of what
exactly is going on under the hood over
here corpus of zero for example so what
I'm doing is I'm converting my just my
words into something you call a bag of
words representation format there are
many ways in which you can represent
words in a way which computers can
understand a very popular way is
something called bag of words so what's
happening in bag of words is you first
you first get your IDs like you if you
based on for example in this particular
case this is our first text before we
did any kind transformation it said
hundred people four so on so we now map
every single word to an ID so hundred
because it's the first word in our
corpus would be zero people would be one
two three so on and so forth
now once you have your indices you do
this so what I'm gonna do over here is
bag of words basically says this
particular index occurs in this document
this many times for example the first
corpus of 0 which is basically just the
transformed version of my first document
word ID 0 appears one time which is why
I have zero comma one word ID 1 appears
3 times which is why you have 1 comma 3
and so on so is everyone able to
understand this particular format of
representing my original data
it's called bag of words there's many
ways to do it this is just one way it's
just clear because it's extremely
important that you know what your data
is supposed to be represented like yes
oh yeah so what dictionary does is it
basically based on your text
it goes through every single word in
your text and assigns an ID or a mapping
to it so every single word now has an ID
so I mean I could do people come up one
and Highland's comma three and stuff
like that but I don't want to you know
computers don't have to deal with words
right so because I want the computer to
only deal with numbers I have 0 1 2 3 so
on and so forth yeah
um a list of lists is what you would
want it to be also think of it which
other kind of format would make sense
yeah so the list of lists of lists is
basically again it doesn't really make
sense so for example are usually the
four for example if you're dealing with
tweets someone mention fits the popular
thing each tweet would be one list and
you would have a lot of tweets so that's
one massive list containing a lot of
tweets I don't see which other data
structure maybe you could have basically
you need any streaming data structure
you know it doesn't need to be a list
like if it streams one by one it's it's
a it'll work I mean if anyone thinks of
any other data structure they can use to
represent it you can stop me maybe numpy
RS which contain words forever but you
would need something like that right so
is this clear because yeah yes you can
so what I've done so what I've also done
is I don't want to destroy my original
text so you can notice as an addiction
is equal to dictionary of texts and I
have a new variable called corpus which
I do which contains texts are not
damaging text and what I'm doing is
dictionary to bow dr. Bell literally
stands for document to bag of words so
I'm doing doctor like document to bag of
words of texts what you do can do is you
can actually go back and you can know
reverse ID dictionary of one is this
word but it's just a pain I mean I would
just not break my text and I would keep
the rest of the things
yes so you do dictionary of one and then
you'd find out the word is people or
Highlands or whatever it is
yeah I've just kind of you can see the
canary of one for example is Sydney so
you'd have to of course write some code
which goes to every single thing and
then makes a loop and then prints it out
it's a pain which is why I didn't
destroy my initial thing but this is
what it looks like so the first thing I
talked about topic modeling before and
what exactly it is so this is our first
topic model which is called Lda it's a
popular topic model 2003 really nice
paper - you should read it if you like
science papers but it's a lot of fun it
happens quite fast and you're going to
see what
so just want to show you what a topic
model looks like over here I created my
topic model I just did LD a model I
called Ally a model from Jensen
I passed my corpus which is my data
after it's been transformed into the way
the computer understands it I said I
want 10 topics and I said ID 2 word
which is my ID toward is my dictionary
and I just gave this much information
and then after that after around two or
three seconds it spat out these topics
for me so right now if we didn't look at
the Australian data set if you had no
idea we would have really no clue about
what's going on under the hood right
like what's actually in my documents now
you kind of have an idea if you'd say
there are 10 topics one topic is about a
fire and you can see there's actually a
lot of fires happening in Australia in
that time so you can okay a lot of them
hear about fires but you can see topic 5
is Union Force government so you can see
maybe there's something about you know
people protesting or something then you
have Israeli and Palestine being a
problem in 2000 so you have to remember
that I did not fine tune the results of
my topic model this is illustrative if
you'd want an ideal topic model I would
run it in many times I would you know
like you can so when you you can go back
and read the documentation for Lda model
but there's things like passes runs
where you see how many times you want to
run it and fine-tune your model to get
better results which you want to see at
this point this is just illustrative to
show you what kind of results you get so
the kind of results you get is 10 topics
so you have topic 0 1 2 3 up to 9 and
you have in that topic what are the most
likely words to appear in that topic in
topic 0 the most likely words are fire
Australian people so on and so forth
topic 1 and so on you can see over here
that it looks like some of the topics
are repeating themselves in which case
choose the number of topics to be 5
instead of 10 so this is the way you bug
your topic model you look at it you're
satisfied or not satisfied and then you
make changes to it I'd like to point out
now that in my github repository which
was talking about before I have a
tutorial on topic modeling where I talk
about what exactly topic modeling is and
how to make how to get better topic
models so I'm not going to go into
details about how to get a better topic
model and
you having a look at my other tutorial
but so what exactly a topic model is
based on the text which you passed
creates topics based on the number of
topics you asked for and it basically
assigns probabilities of words appearing
in that topic later you have documents
which are made out of topics for example
if you'd find a newspaper article which
talks about maybe Australian fires it
would be 94 percent topic 0 4 percent
topic 1 2 percent topic 2 for example so
you can find out what percentage of
topics are in your documents you can
find out what words are in your topics
and using this you can cluster your
documents you can arranger said you can
have a broad view of what exactly is in
your data set you can do a lot with
topic models about what exactly you can
do a topic models check out the other
tutorial this is just to give you an
idea of what topic models are yes this
is a very nice question how can you
evaluate the performance of your topic
model well the thing is because this is
something very subjective it's difficult
to evaluate it so there are some
measures which one is what you call
topic coherence which basically means
how coherent a topic is to a human so
there there are algorithms which try and
estimate the level what you can also do
is you can actually visualize your topic
models and see if it makes tests and
sense in terms of the proportion of
words available so I actually have an
entire section on evaluating topic
models in my topic modeling tutorial so
if you want to see the exact ways I do
it you can check it out but it's a bit
shaky I'll be honest like even the top
research papers in the fields is like
you're not sure so I'm good yeah
so yes it's the probability so the thing
is for example in topic 0 there is 0.06
chance that the word fire would appear
in that now this may not look like a
very high probability but you have to
remember that the entire corpus is so
there's five thousand three hundred
twenty nine words so considering that
that's quite a high probability of that
word appearing in that topic
well not six but 0.6 but yeah yes
absolutely yeah yes
the original corpus I would say briefly
from my experiments might be 3 or 4
topics roughly like I would say 1 this
seems to be a lot of fires going on in
2000 so that's like one massive topic
there's the israeli-palestinian conflict
there's something about Al Qaeda also
coming up I think you might find it here
then I think there's a cricket topic I
mean these are just news so the thing is
to be honest this is not a great topic
model in terms of how useful it is but
it also took around a second to run so I
put almost zero effort into tuning my
topic model so tuning your topic model
requires based on the size of the corpus
you know like having multiple runs
making sure you set your corpus up for
you to get good results so as for how
many topics are inherently present in
the corpus I would say maybe five to
seven but then you cannot really say
there's no ideal number of topics so
it's more of a broad theme also remember
that this is a probabilistic algorithm
so each time you run it there is also
different 100% 100% so oh boy all the
questions that I've been asked so far
more or less have actually been covered
in the topic modeling tutorial which
isn't the same exact repository as this
tutorial so you would actually be able
to find out more about it's really
interesting topic modeling is one of my
favorite parts of text analysis because
just to note that this is completely
unsupervised the only thing I passed to
my model is my corpus I gave it zero
information about it so there's a lot
it's really powerful you can do a lot of
cool things with it just to note I have
only 20 minutes left so I'm gonna kind
of hurry up so I'd appreciate it unless
the question is extremely pressing if
you could ask me after the tutorial bye
because I'm gonna be hanging around here
so just note the question done because I
have 20 minutes left
um text classification how is this
different from topic modeling is that
when we're dealing with text classifier
in computational linguistics and then
topic modeling so I'm gonna continue
doing this briefly introducing topics
and going on about text classification
when we are talking about topic modeling
our data set which we used which was the
Li Corp
had no annotated information we did not
know like the question is asked how many
possible topics is that we had no clue
it was come no information whatsoever
but in the cases a lot of people who
worked in classification problems you
have examples of a certain amount of
classes you have examples of text which
belongs in those classes and you would
want an unseen text to say oh it belongs
in one of these pre-existing classes so
that's what classification is you have a
bunch of classes which you already know
you have data which is already annotated
you use this annotated data with these
classes to create information of what
possible new text could be in which
class and you classify that so this is
another thing which you can do with text
which is classify it the data which are
going to use over here is something
called a twenty ng data set it stands
for twenty newsgroups data set so it's
again a mix of articles which broadly
broken up into twenty different groups
I'm only going to use for excuse me in
these for a thism graphic space and
miscellaneous these are again like
completely random for topics well not
completely random but you know okay so
yeah I'm just getting my imports a few
lines but what's going on over here get
a train so I'm fetching my data set now
some of the things which I want to just
briefly talk about because I'm gonna
really run through this and apologize
about that but I don't know much time ok
number of components five what this
means is that I want to yeah I want to
basically reduce my number of dimensions
to five I'm gonna explain that in a
second labels is basically my values
from my data fetch all Declassified true
values are the actual values okay so
just to give you before we talked about
for example in the previous data set the
size of data set was five thousand six
hundred and thirty nine words so when
you have five thousand sixteen and
thirty nine words when you want to build
a traditional classifier the classifier
actually you know looks at every the
presence or absence of every single word
in your document and then makes a
decision whether or not that word exists
to give you an example of where
text classification is used every single
day it's in spam detection that's a kind
of classification problem with text you
have spam or not spam so based on the
presence or absence of certain words you
usually train a machine learning model
to predict whether a new document is
going to be spam or not spam I mean for
example you need spam you would have
winner or you know like bank or enlarged
or so on and so forth so you know you
have certain words that appear more
often than others presence of these
words means ban your spam not presence
means but the thing is with five
thousand six hundred is actually not so
many words larger corpus is have like
millions of words in them so how do you
deal with that many words how do you
build a classifier which can actually
tackle this you can try and reduce the
number of dimensions where you represent
your 10,000 words or a million words in
less dimensions in this case that's five
why I chose five is because the psychic
learn documentation said she was five
but honestly just you can spend your
time and find out the number of
components you'd want again this is a
game where depending on the size of the
corpus and depending on certain
specifications you would choose it I
think I saw a sign the hand go up yeah
how many minimum words you would need
for a classification I'm not sure but
technically a machine learning algorithm
can work with towards I mean technically
it just would be a very very bad maybe
five thousand I would say but then again
you know I'm like honestly I'm just kind
of winging it but of course just as a
usual ball mark like more words are
better too many words gets messy I mean
it's doesn't sound like great advice but
that's how it is
vectorizer so what my vectorizer is
initially I talked about how computers
cannot understand numbers so I wrecked
ERISA which basically means I convert my
words into numbers you've no doubt you
might notice I've written tf-idf
vectorizer tf-idf previously we use bag
of words right we use bag of words to
represent the number of words which we
have so I basically used a bag of words
to represent the number of words I have
in my document tf-idf it stands for
frequency in risk document frequency
where it based on more words and
document means that word is represented
more if this were it appears in a lot of
documents means it's not so important I
mean I'm kind of rushing to this again
but tf-idf is basically a way you can
represent your words to a computer so
you can maybe search about it and find
out if you want to know more about
tf-idf it's just a way to represent
words so i'm vectorizing it using that x
train fit transform basically means I'm
transforming my data to the
specification which I've mentioned
before which is my vectorizer then SVD
stands for a singular value
decomposition which is a matrix where's
my damn house yeah which is a matrix
factorization method which basically
reduces the number of dimensions I
mentioned five a number of components
what happens then I normalize it and LSA
is again another part of this
pre-processing step which stands for
latent semantic analysis which basically
creates your number of dimensions so I
know that I really am aware of the fact
that I really really rushed through this
just some of the key words I used tf-idf
which you should probably search up SVD
and LSA what and use what I'm doing
using tf-idf SVD and LSA is basically
reducing the number of dimensions I have
to a lot less to a better number so that
it's easier for me to build my
classifier these are considered standard
pre-processing steps when you want to
build a classifier I would recommend if
you want to know more about each of
these single ones to search about each
of those single ones or just talk to me
after this is over so now I get my data
and I am going to I'm extracting my
features so all of this would you saw
until now was actually just my setup I
basically just wrecked Erised set up my
data like you saw the pre-processing I
did before that was manual
pre-processing the reason I showed you
that is to show you the amount of
control you can have the through
pre-processing you can also also ask me
is there a helper function to do this
yeah these are the helper functions so I
did absolutely nothing if you might have
noticed I didn't remove top words but
when I'm using stop words English over
there I don't know if you can notice
this over here yeah
so it's happening so there are helper
functions to do it but I wanted to show
you how Spacey gives you the power to
really play around with it you can hurry
up and do a psychic learn and other
packages have pre ways to sort your text
out so what am i doing over here I mean
she talked about the spam not spam one
of the earliest algorithms for this spam
not spam was got a Gaussian a base which
is a kind of where you kind of use the
probability of the word appearing in a
document to see if that word is spam or
not spam so it's not super complicated
probability and statistics it's actually
really fun if you get into the details
behind it I'm going to recommend you to
google it so here we go what's going on
over here so the second the classify
modem is something called SVM which is
support vector machine it's also really
really fun it kind of splits our data
into a different dimension space where
you can kind of separate into different
classes so these are the two kinds of
machine learning algorithms these are
probably the two most popular basic
classifying algorithms so once so what
we did before is we set up our tf-idf
vectorizer reducer dimensions made sure
data was ready for the algorithm then we
trained our machine learning models
which here was one model was the
Gaussian air base the other model was
the support vector machine and once
we've trained our models after we
transformed our data we make our
predictions so you can see over here is
0 comma 3 comma 3 so on means document
the first document was classified into
class 0 second document into class 3 and
so on and so forth yeah so that's a lot
of information I just threw what you
folks is everyone ok any hands going up
anything you want ask me yeah no they're
very different have been clear ok so can
we let you finish yeah ok I'm just going
to clarify this because it's very
important but these you might have also
noticed we used two different data sets
for topic modeling we use the lis corpus
just talking about it all the newspaper
information
and it was only it was unlabeled we had
like I meant like you saw before there
was absolutely no information about the
corpus I want to find out things about
my corpus so I used topic modeling to
look for maybe hidden structures which
happen to be my topics in text
classification we are very aware of the
classes in this case it's atheism
miscellaneous graphics and space we are
aware of these four topics we have four
classes I'm sorry we're aware of these
four classes and we have a data set
which has documents with these classes
annotated and we have documents where
it's not so we are training first what
we do is we transform our data in which
towaway it can be understood and after
we do that we train a classifier which
learns what kind of words are more
likely for it to be in one of these four
classes it looks at a new document which
it does not know and then based on this
information it puts it into one of these
four classes so we know what the classes
are it's a label data set and our
problem is rather fine-tuned I mean be
there's a certain thing which we wish to
achieve and which is put this document
into a class based on labeled
information topic modeling is different
because you really don't know anything
and it's more exploratory so again like
I mentioned before what we started off
was computational linguistics I mean
pre-processing computational linguistics
topic modeling text classification these
are all related but completely different
tasks again like I mentioned before I
want to give you more breath than depth
I want to give you an idea of the
different kinds of things these are all
quite different things yeah so the last
part of the tutorial is going to be so
again just to clarify these are three
separate tasks which we did and now
we're done with them for now and now
we're going to deep learning which is
the final part I would like to mention
that there's seven minutes left so I'm
really really going to run through this
part I would have liked to take more
time but you are more than welcome to
stop me afterwards just honestly if you
download
tutorial things should be pretty easy
but right now it's gonna be really
really fast yeah so um deep learning
deep learning basically stands for
machine learning which uses neural
networks and we're using neural networks
which have lots of layers because they
have lots it's quite arbitrary but it
let's say more than eight layers roughly
you would call something a deep learning
algorithm so again deep learning would
be very roughly machine learning using
neural networks neural networks lots of
layers deep learning kind of again these
definitions do vary and shouldn't take
my word 100% for it but this is roughly
what deep learning is just by the way
there's also shallow learning that's
actually a thing and it's also very cool
for text but right now what we're going
to be doing doing is using deep learning
to try and generate text what I mean by
generating text is we have access to
text documents before and you want to
try and mimic this text or generate text
the best way to do this is using a kind
of neural network called a recurrent
neural network and in recurrent neural
networks is a particular kind called
LS TM Alice tiems which stands for long
short term memory are useful because
when we want to generate text what's
really important is context a long short
term memory has the ability to
understand this context and based on
words which are appeared before and we
try to predict what are the odds of a
certain word appearing next and you
predict this word by predicting words
we're generating text so it can look
like a machine is actually writing like
for example if you train it on
Shakespeare text it's going to look like
it's writing Shakespeare I cannot
recommend this these two block-posts
enough understanding others TM networks
and the unreasonable effectiveness of
recurrent neural networks they're about
text they're very well written they
explain the intuition of these neural
networks and the things you can do with
it
again could not recommend it enough
please check my notebook and read these
blog posts for this part of the tutorial
we're going to be using the code from
this github repository so it more or
less follows the code from there so
honestly at this part because I have
five minutes
I'm literally just going to press ENTER
so I apologize I really also because
this takes some time to train and I'm
going to briefly run you through the
code so don't be alarmed but it takes
some time because yeah okay
okay okay
superfast what's happening over here
first some using tears to get all my
imports talk about LF TMS and sequential
leaves basically okay so the imports are
basically the tools I'm going to be
using to build my noodle Network I want
the the next bit of code is for you to
understand what exactly categorical or
one hot encoding means here we're
basically going to say a particular
document we talk if it contains or does
not contain a word by the presence of
one so for example over here you can see
that there are zeros and ones and based
on the presence or absence of a certain
ID you have zero or one it's basically
binary encoding which is the kind of
encoding which these you know this is
the language the neural networks
understand this is the information that
she'll be passing to the neural network
some so new electorates itself honestly
could be a tutorial of its own or two or
three drove it technically a
semester-long course so I'm not going to
get into details about exactly how
neural networks function right now you
can think of it as a magical black box
which does cool stuff but again like I
mentioned the two blog posts I talked
about before will kind of make these
things more clear but what I'm doing
over here there is something that you're
important one is drop rate activation so
what these exactly mean is sometimes for
a particular data set neural networks
tend to over generalize which means that
they tend to work only well for that
particular data set when this is
happening we want to drop out so we have
things like drop rates activation here
basically stands for when we get
information and you want to activate
each neuron what kind of function you're
using in this case we're using softmax
which is a kind of activation function
so these are keywords which are regard
to the way neural networks are built
again like I said I'm not going to talk
about exactly how you build them and the
curious documentation actually has a
does a pretty good job in explaining
what each of these parts of the neural
networks are so you have these are the
parts when I'm creating my model this is
what I'm doing you can see over here I
say input and then I talk about my input
shape which basically puts my dimensions
out for it then I've talked about LST M
again I'll Jim long short term memory
good for building context this is my
basic model then dropout and dents
basically talks about when do I want to
drop out in size of M origin rising and
dents talks about the kind of new
elaborate layer in which case here is a
dense layer pardon me
now here we create our model using the
information attacker before you have
drop active mode number of dimensions
then you have a flag and over here I
again so these are just basically the
steps which I'm using to create my model
again I'm not again I have a minute left
so I'm really aren't gonna get into this
but then as for training my model you
have a loss function a loss function is
again a part of the neural network she
decides how its trained same with their
optimizer these tend to be so all of the
heat all of the variables
hyperparameters have chosen here kind of
optimized for text generation so you can
kind of use the same hyperparameters for
your experiments as well and what I'm
doing over here this is so this is a fun
part I'm going to actually talk about
the so once I've created my new electric
the actual text generation part happens
over here so I basically want to predict
the next word given a certain bunch of
words happening that in the past for
example when I talked about if you want
to talk for example there is all a bunch
of you can imagine this a bunch of new
electric so there is trying to predict
what trump says so but predict is kind
of complicated what the style in which
he talks like but for example if he says
and this is a character by character
text generation model okay knowing now
if we're trained on a lot of Trump
tweets if the first word of the first
letter of a word which Trump starts the
capital S it's highly likely he's gonna
say sad right so out here now we know
he's going to say sad because he says
that
but so does a neural network so on
seeing s a capital s capital one because
he all uses capitals for said when a
sees a capital S it's likely that the
next word is going to be a capital A so
now what we do is we get probabilities
and we predict that the highest
probability is for a and we generate
text based on what is the most likely
word what happens over here my so a lot
of training which is going on over here
which trains my model and so yeah out of
time out of battery so uh but you can
see we're here because I'm training on
okay really really fast because this is
like the last so you can see hat is all
that we had hope for the videotape
showed bin Laden speaking to support in
a room war that's but dark but you can
see over here the the reason it
predicted this is because we are
training on newspaper data based on
al-qaeda and bin Laden and so on and so
forth so it is pretty much writing its
own newspaper article based on the
newspaper articles it read so that's
what my noodle Network is doing over
here so this is the last example of my
text analysis tutorial really really
fast the things we talked about the
packages we're going to use the
importance of way of getting your data
from how important it is to clean your
text computational linguistics topic
modeling text classification deep
learning these are a bunch of cool
things you've learnt about I would
really recommend checking this tutorial
out in more detail later I have a lot of
reading material and stuff online as
well so I hope you fellas had fun
[Applause]
you
[Applause]